whereas to graph the following equation
y equals 5x squared minus 20x plus 15 so
let me get my little scratch pad out so
it's y is equal to 5x squared minus 20x
plus 15 now there's many ways to graph
this you can just take three values for
X and figure out what the corresponding
values for Y are just graph those three
points and three points actually will
determine a parabola but I want to do
something a little bit more interesting
I want to find the places so if we
imagine our axes if we imagine our axes
this is my x axis that's my y axis and
this is our curve so the parabola might
look something like this I want to first
figure out where does this parabola
intersect the x axis and as we've
already seen intersecting the x axis is
the same thing as saying when does this
parabola equal when does y equal zero
for this parabola or another way of
saying it when does this 5x squared
minus 20x plus 15 when does this equal
zero so I want to figure out those
points and then I also want to figure
out the point exactly in between which
is the vertex and if I can graph those
three points then I should be all set
with graphing this parabola so as I just
said we're going to try to solve the
equation 5x squared minus 20x plus 15 is
equal to zero now the first thing I like
to do whenever I see a coefficient out
here on the x squared term that's not a
1 is to see if I can divide everything
by that term to try to simplify this a
little bit and maybe this will get us
into a factorable form and we does look
like every term here is divisible by 5
so I will divide by 5 so I'll divide
both sides of this equation by 5 and so
that will give me these cancel out and I
am left with x squared minus 20 over 5
is 4x plus 15 over 5 is 3 is equal to 0
over 5 is just 0 and now we can attempt
to factor this left-hand side we say are
there two numbers whose product is
positive 3 the fact that their product
is positive tells you that they
both must be positive and whose sum is
negative 4 which tells you all they both
must be negative if we're getting a
negative sum here and the one that
probably jumps out at your mind and you
might want to review the videos on
factoring polynomials if this is not so
fresh is negative 3 and negative 1 seem
to work negative 3 times negative 1
negative 3 times negative 1 is 3
negative 3 plus negative 1 is negative 4
so this will factor out as X minus 3
times X minus 1 and on the right hand
side we still have that being equal to 0
and now we can think about what X's will
make this expression 0 and if they make
this expression 0 well they're going to
make this expression 0 which is going to
make this expression equal to 0 and so
this will be true if either one of these
is 0 so X minus 3 is equal to 0 or X
minus 1 is equal to 0 this is true and
you can add 3 to both sides of this this
is true when X is equal to 3 this is
true when X is equal to 1 so we were
able to figure out these two points
right over here this is X is equal to 1
this is X is equal to 3 so this is the
point 1 comma 0 this is the point 3
comma 0 and so the last one I want to
figure out is this point right over here
the vertex now the vertex always sits
exactly smack-dab between the roots when
you do have roots sometimes you might
not intersect the x axis so we already
know what its
x-coordinate is going to be it's going
to be 2 and now we just have to
substitute back in to figure out its
y-coordinate when x equals 2 y is going
to be equal to Y is going to be equal to
5 times 2 squared minus 20 times 2 plus
15 which is equal to let's see this is
equal to 2 squared is 4 this is 20 minus
40 plus 15 so this is going to be
negative 20 plus 15 which is equal to
negative 5 so this is a point 2 comma
negative 5 and so now we can go back to
the exercise and actually plot these 3
points 1 comma 0 2 comma negative 5 3
comma 0 so let's do that so first I'll
do the vertex at 2 comma negative 5
which is right there and now we also
know one of the times that intersects
the x-axis is at 1 comma 0 and the other
time is at 3 comma 0 and now we can
check our answer and we got it right